foreign
before moving on to your questions we
have as usual a few
announcements first i would like to
welcome on behalf
of the president and the whole college
the adoption
of the next long-term eu budget by the
eu legislators
all the conditions have now been
fulfilled for the next multi-annual
financial framework to be in place
as of the 1st of january 2021
making almost 1.1 trillion euro
available for beneficiaries
of eu funding during the next seven
years
once the new owned resources decision is
approved by member states in accordance
with their constitutional requirements
we will also be able to launch
next generation eu to fuel europe's
recovery
we will then have an additional amount
firepower if you wish
of 750 billion euros to provide european
people
businesses regions and cities with the
support
they urgently need to recover from the
pandemic
we can now start building a greener more
digital and more resilient
europe ready for today's and tomorrow's
challenges
more information is available online in
a press release
and a question and answers and now let
me pass the floor to stefan who has good
news on the vaccine front
stephan
pharmaceuticals
foreign
m finally
i would like to recall that the fifth
ordinary meeting of the eu
uk joint committee will begin in a few
moments
vice president mao shefkovic will make a
statement in the vip corner at around
2 45 this afternoon
this concludes our announcements for
today and
we are ready to take your questions i
start with
david
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
on vaccinations
do you hear me yes yes yeah i'm sorry my
question is on a court case between the
european commission and slovenia not on
the vaccines okay
we will come back to you later
um lily
lily you have the floor
we can see you lily
you have your mask on i hope your
microphone is on the right source
okay we've lost you um
sorry it's not on the subject i see okay
caroline
yes thank you eric for taking my
question it isn't indeed on the vaccine
given the fact that that the first
vaccine now seems to be around the
corner
could you give us the latest in on the
eu commission's efforts to bring the
vaccine to other parts of the world as
well
both logistically and financially
especially considerating the fact that
the biontech vaccine needs special
storage and that
might be difficult for other parts of
the world and i would be interested in
the eu commission's efforts to
to facilitating the rollout of the
vaccine in these parts of the world
thank you thank you well what i can say
is that this is indeed an issue
which um is being looked into seriously
by the college you may have seen
uh this morning that there was a meeting
of the group of commissioners
dealing with the coronavirus the
response during which uh this specific
issue was raised what i can say
is that lots of contacts are taking
place
with countries for example in our
neighborhood
and also of course more widely
in the context of the kovacs facility so
these are ongoing efforts
um that will come to fruition of course
later on but let me just remind you of
one thing this is not related
solely to the first vaccine that will
become available we have been
negotiating
a portfolio of vaccines some
we hope will be approved at a later
stage they will all have
different conditions different
constraints some lighter some heavier
when it comes
to the conditions under which they can
be shipped around
and all this needs to be taken into
account
let us stick on questions related to
vaccination
might i would ask you to unraise your
hand please for the moment we will come
back to you i've noted down your name
tommaso you have a question on vaccines
yes good morning thomas gallaudet and
chronos it's just
a simple question it's uh i apologize
for the
for being repetitive but it would be
useful if you could
repeat as the procedure after the
possible green light by the ema
to the vaccine uh developed by
fight ceremony i guess that it passes
from comatology
and but if you if you could remind us of
the procedure after it would be
useful thank you thank you tommaso
indeed i think this has been described a
certain number of times here on the
podium and also
in some of our documents but i passed
the floor to stefan
thank you very much tommaso indeed i
think you will find some in the useful
information in the q and a's that we
have
published last friday but just to
explain in a few words
one once we have a positive
recommendation from emma
the commission indeed has to take a
decision authorizing
the marketing of this vaccine
to do so the commission goes checks a
few elements
it will also consult with the member
states in the context of what you indeed
correctly refer to as commentology
member states will be asked for their
opinion
and following the opinion the
endorsement of the member states
the commission can then take its
decision putting the product
on the market i would like to stress
that we will do this within two days
in a similar cases this procedure is
something that could take up to 60
67 days so we are really speeding up the
process
as much as we can but more information
as i said you will find on
our q a document on the press corner
published last friday
thank you okay we continue on this
theme griselda
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
launcher vaccination
jillian
hi thanks so much my i just want to
double check the that i have the
logistics of the vaccine distribution
done accurately
so the vaccine days will be december
27th to the 29th
and the ema is going to meet this coming
monday 21st
um and then i'll take what two days for
the commission to approve that vaccine
and then
deliveries will start on the 26th is
that all correct
um i will pass the flow to stefan but as
far as i understand
yes i mean the commission has up to
three days we've said
in order to deliver its decision on the
placing on the market um but
uh it's you know a maximum period we'll
see
in what time frame we can do it but
apart from that i think it's correct
stefan can you confirm
uh yes indeed so first we have we need
the commission to take the decision
putting the vaccine on the market which
will be done within
two days as i explained and then the
deliveries um have to take place
deliveries by the company
to the member states and then it's of
course still possible but this has to be
organized by the member states their
distributions take place from the
central vaccine hub
to other vaccination centers in the
member states
and this is how it uh will be organized
thank you stefan jillian
yes sorry okay so just to make sure that
so the vaccine clubs
are i know a lot of the vaccine
producers for the bio and tech and
physio vaccine are in belgium in germany
so i'm 26 that's when these you know
assuming that it's approved those will
start to be rolled out
it can be assumed then that probably
belgium germany will get these vaccines
first before then they start to get to
all the other eu countries and that's
why you have three separate vaccine days
no you can't you can't deduce uh one
from the other jillian
the fact is that we are in contact with
member states um
and uh it is considered wiser in view
of the size of the european union the
diversity
of situations to have a certain number
of days
to launch to launch the campaign but the
vaccines will
will be will start being delivered on
the on the 26th
i see no further questions on this issue
so i come back to moyta
yes hi thank you thanks again my
question is on a court case delivered
today
by the european court of justice and i
want to
how does the commission come and this
judgment in the case
uh commission versus slovenia in
relation to the unviability of the
archives of the
european central bank and another thing
was there any kind of talks between the
commission and the slovenian government
before this judgment
uh following the letter by the prime
minister janice yancha
looking for a way for the commission to
withdraw
the uh the action at the court thank you
thank you this is a question for martha
thank you thank you very much for your
questions on the first
on the comment of the commission on this
case um so the commission takes note of
today's judgment
of the court of justice in the
infringement case that it brought
against slovenia
the court confirms that slovenia
infringed the principle of
unavailability of the archives of the
union by unilaterally seizing documents
that
are part of the archives of the european
central bank
and the particularity of this case was
that those archives were not stored at
the premises of the ecb
but actually at the premises of the
slovenian central bank
in its role as part of the european
system of central banks and its
functions
under the eu law the court also rules
that
by not cooperating properly with the ecb
slovenia failed
to fulfill its obligations of sincere
cooperation
the commission will of course now study
in more details this ruling
in particular given its importance from
the perspective of
understanding what constitute an archive
of the union and now when it comes to
your
second question on the
contacts between the commission and the
and the slovenian government
uh you might remember indeed that uh the
commission president has received a
letter
uh this summer from the prime minister
and uh the president replied
uh of course to this letter in her
response the president
confirmed the willingness of the
commission to keep the dialogue open
with slovenia on this matter in the
spirit of sincere cooperation of course
as with all member states
but the commission understands that the
slovenian authorities and the ecb
have been discussing the matter without
success
thank you very much
thank you is there another question on
this
specific court case perhaps from petra
is it on this beta yes it is
we cannot hear you almost uh let's raise
the sound level
you see your microsource is correct it's
just it's very low okay go ahead
yes i have a follow-up question um could
you
tell us marta what exactly do you expect
slovenia to do now
and if there is any time frame in which
the judgment has to be implemented thank
you
martha thank you very much thank you
very much petra i can be extremely brief
of course on this matter as with all
court judgment we expect slovenia to
comply with the judgment that was issued
today
thank you thank you
are there other questions on this
specific court case
georgie you have a question on this
court case
if not please don't raise your hand okay
thank you so i know i now go to leonel
i know you have a question on another
court case
[Music]
um
um
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
please only keep your hand raised if it
is on this
lorne you have a question on this
yes i do uh law and corporate associated
press um
i noticed when you were when you were
reading out your
um the commission's position there that
some of the elements
actually seem to to resemble um
what the pact for asylum and migration
is planning to do in the greek islands
for example the border procedures
and the detention of asylum seekers uh
under the under the pact proposals you
are in fact
uh suggesting that the greek islands
will become like a kind of an airport
transit lounge where where uh people who
are in there have no
no particular right of having actually
entered european territory
uh they may be kept in detention
throughout that procedure
member states can do that doesn't that
seem a little hypocritical
thank you lauren i think i need to be
very very clear about this the pact
and the the proposals that we made as
part of the fact are based on very sound
principles which include
effective access to the asylum procedure
full protection of fundamental rights
and any any procedures that
are part of the proposals are based on
sound guarantees
uh in eu law including for example um
any applicable time limits when it comes
to
um any use of detention or um the
the uh right to an effective remedy um
in case of any negative decisions or in
fact any
decisions affecting asylum seekers or
persons subject to return procedure
similarly any detention
decisions under you law need to be
individual and
these these guarantees are fully present
in the new pact on migration asylum
while the today's judgment concerns the
the violation in hungarian law of
many of these these essential issues so
i would not i would not
compare the the proposals and the new
pact which again fully respect
fundamental rights
with the issue at stake today
thank you very much i think this closes
the issue so i opened the floor to other
issues and we tried to go back to
lilly who had raised her hand among the
very first
lily go ahead
can you hear me yeah sorry about the
technical issues earlier
um i have a question about president
fronderlin
given that she was at the european
council
summit and given that president emmanuel
macron has tested positive
for the coronavirus i was wondering uh
first of all when the president's last
preston funder line's last
cova test took place and whether she
plans on self-isolating
right now thank you thank you her last
coffee test took place
on monday as every week and no she has
no plans on self-isolating
are there other questions on this
particular issue although to be honest i
have very little to add
enrique you have a question on this
[Music]
[Music]
um yes thank you absolutely the meetings
are actually taking place as we speak
so unfortunately i'm not in a position
for the moment to give you a readout
but of course um as soon as i
as i'm in a position to send you
something in writing i'll be happy to do
so
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
uh
maybe you can see me also
um
i have a question on venezuela hi er
do we have something new on venezuela
under recognizing of the national
assembly after the meeting
from foreign ministers in berlin this
week thank you
thank you this will be a question for
nabila
[Music]
but not much to add to what
the hrvp has said at the fac on
on venezuela as you know
we will have maybe more news on the 5th
of january but at this point
i cannot add anything to what the hrvp
has said following the fac where the
the question on venezuela was actually
part of the
of the issues discussed by the foreign
ministers
thank you are there other questions on
foreign affairs for nabila today
maria
uh can you hear me yes apologies for
that
yeah don't worry okay i'm asking you one
thing
uh concerning uh julia originally any
case
uh you know the italian foreign minister
luigi
mario has proposed to
involve a directly european union to put
pressure on egypt on this case
so i'm asking you uh has italy
already contacted you are you
i mean the european commission or the
eis
activating in some ways and
are there any sanction on the table so
what can you tell me about thank you
thank you giuseppe for your questions
um as you know the european union
continues to follow the
closely the case of giulio regeni we
have always raised
the case in our bilateral meetings and
contacts
asking the egyptian authorities to fully
cooperate with the italian authorities
in order to clarify the circumstances of
the death
of regeni this case
matters for the entire european union
not just for a member states
we we have and we will continue closely
to liaise with the
italian authorities who have our false
full support
and as we said from the beginning the
european union stands
at the side of the regine family to help
finding the truth as for your questions
on on sanction
as you know under the sanctioned regime
or
in general in any sanction regime it is
up and it is ultimately for the council
to decide
and so far i'm not aware of any
discussions between
the hrvp and italian foreign minister
thank you are there other questions on
foreign relations
issues for nabila or for
peter today peter's not here yes
so but you would take them i do not see
any
so are there other questions for us
today
nikolai
yes nicole nielsen e observer can you
hear me yes
yes yes thank you i had a
migraine migration related question so
for the past nine months around 1 000
people
including some 300 kids have been living
in the malacasa camp outside of athens
so this site received 4.9 million euros
of eu funding from the amos
anyways the tents are water law and
there is no running water
so it doesn't seem normal that for 4.9
million euros
there is still no running water after
nine months
and that people are forced to live in
waterlogged tents
so my question to you is the commission
satisfied
how european taxpayer money is being
spent
in this particular camp thank you
thank you a question for adelberl
thank you nikolai um i um i am of course
aware of the
the general difficulties in many
reception centers in greece particularly
on
uh on the islands and as you know the
commission is very actively involved
with the greek authorities
in supporting them in order to improve
the situation
in the in the different camps i do not
have to hand specific information about
the malacasa camp
so if you if you allow us i will get
back to you on this more specifically
thanks thank you
are there other questions for adelberg
today
that is not the case so i go back to
tomaso
tommaso you have the floor
yes good morning it's a question for
competition if i may
it's about eva because
i've read that this morning that
domenicor curry who's the
ceo of invitage said that the italian
authorities notified to the commission
the operation by which
in vitalia acquires uh the
part of the business which uh
manages the former ilva steel plant in
toronto
i wonder if you can confirm us that this
is the case
and if you are considering the matter
thank you
ayanna
we cannot hear you ayanna
sorry i had muted myself do you hear me
now
go ahead okay thanks so
um tommaso as far as i know
this transaction has not been notified
to the commission
it is up to the companies to notify uh
to the commission
if the transaction has an uh eu
dimension
um if it has been said of course it
could have happened in the last minute
so
uh i would be very happy to double check
and and get back to you
thank you ariana other questions on
competition policy for ariana today
tomas do you have a follow-up
no no yes no no yes okay
no no no good thank you
okay any other questions for us today
no so thank you very much and see you
tomorrow for what will be
the last midday of the
year thank you very much see you
tomorrow